The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: All right.
I want to thank
you all for coming
to the third lecture of
the Signal Processing
on Databases class.
So we will go-- just
to remind folks,
all the material is
available in the distribution
of the software,
which you all have
in your [INAUDIBLE] accounts.
Here, we're going to
go to lecture two.
Courses.
Course, which
brings it together.
Signal processing,
which is based
on detection theory, which
is based on linear algebra
with databases, which are
based on strings and searching
and really bringing those
two concepts together
in the course.
So that we can use
the mathematics
we know from detection theory
and apply it into new domains.
And I'm glad to see we
have a full house again.
So far, I've failed
in scaring off people.
So we'll see if we
can do a better job.
I think this particular
lecture should
do a very good job of that.
We're going to be
getting into a little bit
some more of the
mathematics that
underpins the associative array
construct that is in the D4M
technology that we're
using in the class
and gets into some group
theory concepts that might be
a long time since any of
you had any of that or even
recall what that is.
It's actually not
that complicated.
Personally, this is
my favorite lecture
in terms of it really gets into
the deeper underlying elements.
I would fully expect it to make
your head hurt a little bit.
We're going to do sort
of a fairly rapid blast
through the mathematics here.
And you won't really
have to know this really
to effectively use it.
Although, it's good
to know that it exists
and that there might
be pieces of it
that you'll want to
drive into deeper.
And so really, the
title of this talk
is called Spreadsheets,
Big Tables, and the Algebra
Associative Arrays.
We've lectured on that
topic in the past.
So with that, we will
get right into it.
So here's the outline
for the lecture.
And I should say,
you know, there's
a balance between
the lecture, and then
we'll have some examples.
This particular lecture will
be a little bit more heavy
on the lecture side.
And the example piece
is a little bit shorter.
And so a little bit more lecture
and a little less example
on this particular class.
So we're going to talk about
kind of a mathematical concept
for what are spreadsheets.
And in the
introduction here, talk
about what our
theoretical goals are,
really what
associative arrays are.
Getting into the
mathematical definitions,
what is the group theory?
And then leading into the sort
of traditional linear algebra,
vector spaces and
other types of things,
sort of getting
you a sense of this
really is what connects those
two things at the deeper
mathematical level.
So what are spreadsheets
and big tables?
So spreadsheets--
obviously, Microsoft Excel
tends to dominate the
spreadsheet world--
are arguably the most commonly
used analytics structure
on Earth.
Probably 100 million people,
if not a larger number,
use a spreadsheet
every single day.
Perhaps a good the
fraction of the planet
now has used a spreadsheet
at some point or the other.
Big tables, which are
these large triple store
databases that we have
discussed in prior lectures,
are really what is used to
store most of the analyzed data
on Earth.
So Google, Amazon, they all
have these giant triple store
databases, which can be thought
about as gigantic spreadsheets
really, rows and columns
and values and stuff.
And the power is that they
really can simultaneously
store diverse data.
You can hold in the same
data structure strings,
and dates, and
integers, and reels,
and all different types of data.
And you can treat
them very differently.
As we've shown here, this
is just one spreadsheet.
We can treat it as a matrix.
We can treat it as functions,
hash table, little mini
databases.
All in the same
spreadsheet, we can kind of
hold this information.
So it's a very powerful
concept, the spreadsheet.
Yet, we lack any formal
mathematical basis for this.
In fact, I looked up in
the American Mathematical
Association in the SIAM
databases the word spreadsheet.
And it did not appear
in a single title
or an abstract other than,
say, maybe with reference
to some software.
But this core thing
that we use every day--
every single time we do a
Google search we're using it,
every single time
we do a spreadsheet,
we're using it-- has no
formal mathematical structure.
And so that seems like a
little bit of a problem.
Maybe we should have some
formal mathematical structure.
And so this mathematical thing
called an associative array
actually gives us a
mathematical structure that
really encompasses this
in a fairly nice way.
I'm sure there's
cases that it doesn't.
But the core of what it
is really, really works.
So I think that's
a powerful concept.
So what is our
overall goal here?
So we want to create
a formal basis
for working with these types
of data structures in a more
mathematically rigorous way.
This allows us to create
better algorithms.
Because we can now apply
the traditional tools
of linear algebra and detection
theory to these types of data.
It saves time in
terms of, generally,
if you have the
mathematical background,
you can implement things
using a lot less code, which
usually means a lot less lines.
And often, you can
build on top of existing
optimized libraries, which
give you better performance.
And we throw out a number
of 50 x less effort.
For those with the required
training, they can do this.
And that is something that we've
observed a number of occasions.
And you know, it's
good for managers, too.
I've tried to recruit group
leaders at Lincoln Laboratory.
It's like, you really
should use D4M.
I could connect it
to SAP no problem.
Get them feeling like they're
actually doing programming
again, you know?
I haven't had too many
takers of that yet.
So hopefully, maybe as
you folks start using it,
they'll see you using it.
Binding to the
various enterprise
databases at the laboratory
is very easy to do.
And using D4M to analyze
it is fairly easy to do.
So I actually use it now instead
of-- if I'm going to use Excel,
I'll often be like, no,
I'll just write a CSV file
and just use D4M for
manipulating basic Excel
types of operations.
Because it feels a lot
more natural to me.
And so I certainly
have done that.
So we're going to get into
this associative array
concept, which we discussed in
some of the earlier lectures.
We're going to get into
it more deeply now.
But the real benefit of the
associative array concept
is it naturally pulls
together four different ways
of thinking about your
data into one structure.
And you can apply the
reasoning from any
of these four ways of thinking
sort of interchangeably now.
So we can think about data
as associative arrays,
as arrays that are
indexed by words.
This is similar to what Perl
does in hashes of hashes, where
we can have row
keys that are words,
and column keys that
are words, and then
values that are
words or numbers.
This concept is one to one with
our triple store databases.
So we can go naturally
from triples to this
and inserting data
into a database.
And if our data is
an associative array,
we can very quickly say,
please insert into a database.
And if we do a query, it can
return an associative array
to us very nicely.
This obviously
connects to graphs
if we want to store
relationships and graphs
between vertices and entities.
So we have alice,
bob, cited, which
is a duel to the
linear algebraic matrix
formulation of graphs.
Row, Alice, column, Bob, their
edge associated between them.
So we have these four
very powerful ways
of looking at our data.
And they're now all
sort of brought together
as one concept.
So I kind of argued it's one
of the best deals in math
you'll get.
If you know one, you get
the other three for free.
And that's really what the
whole point of math is, right?
If you give me a whole
bunch of information,
I can calculate something
else that you didn't know.
And typically, in
signal processing
that deal is more
like, well, if give me
50 pieces of information,
I can give you the 51st.
Here, if you give me one,
I can give you three.
So it's a really good bargain.
As a little anecdote, I was
working with my daughter
teaching her the parallel
geometry lines problem.
You know, parallel lines.
I was telling her this
is the best deal in math.
Because you know one angle, and
you get the other seven free.
So we're not quite
as good as that.
That's probably the
best deal in math going.
And that's why they
teach it so much.
If you know one angle, you
get the other seven for free.
Here, if you know one
of these concepts,
you essentially get
the other for free.
So it's a very powerful concept.
And it's really kind of
at the core of the benefit
of this technology.
As much as possible,
we try and make it
that any operation on
an associative array
returns another
associative array.
So this gives you sort of
the mathematical concept
of closure.
Linear algebra works
because the vast majority
of operations on a matrix
return another matrix.
And so you can compose these
together mathematically
and create sequences
of operation,
which are conceptually
easy to think about.
So because of that, we
can create operations
like adding associative arrays,
subtracting associative arrays,
anding, [? warring ?] them,
multiplying them together.
And the result of every
one of these operations
will be another
associative array.
And so that's a very
powerful, powerful concept.
And likewise, we can do
very easy query operations
if we want to get rows Alice
and Bob, row Alice, rows
beginning with al, rows Alice
to Bob, the first two rows,
everything equal to 47.
And every single one
of these will return
another associative array.
So again, this
compositional concept
is very, very important.
It's not to say we don't use
the triples formulation, too.
And we have routines that
very quickly bounce you
back and forth between them.
Because there are
times you're just like,
no, I want to view this
is as a set of triples.
And I want to do new
operations that way as well.
So we support them both.
But this is really sort of
the core composable aspect.
In fact, most people
initially develop their codes
in this formalism,
and then maybe
change some of their lines
to working on native triples
if they need to get some
improvement in performance,
memory handling, or
the side like that.
And we certainly do that, too.
These associative
arrays are actually
very easy to implement.
And the whole D4M library-- it's
probably a little larger now,
but when I wrote this--
it was about 2,000 lines,
At which is very easy to do in
programming environments that
have first class support for
two dimensional arrays, operator
overloading.
We're overloading
operators here like crazy
here, the plus, the minus,
the and, parentheses,
all that kind of stuff.
And also, have
first class support
for sparse linear algebra.
Internal, under
the covers, we're
using sparse linear algebra like
crazy to make all this work.
Of the languages on Earth
that have those features,
MATLAB is by far the
most popular one,
which is why we have
chosen that language
to implement these features.
There are other languages
that have these features.
And you can implement that.
But there are other
languages that don't.
And if you want to implement
D4M in those languages,
you certainly can.
You just have to
write more code.
So this is sort of the language
in which it can be done
in the minimum amount of code.
And again, we find that
for complex analytics
that people typically
can get their work done
with 50 times less code than
equivalent Java and SQL.
And this naturally leads to
high performance parallel
implementations, because these
are all arrays and matrices.
And we have a very
well-established literature
in the community about how to
do parallel linear algebra,
how to make matrices
work in parallel.
It's a very
well-studied discipline.
And we have a lot of technology.
Just to remind people
of how we actually
store the data in our databases
and how the data will often
come out in our
associate arrays,
we use this exploded schema.
So if we had data that
looked like a standard table
here with some kind of
key and three columns
here with different
values associated
with every one of them,
if we were to insert these
into a standard,
say, SQL type table,
we would just simply create
a table like this in SQL.
But if we wanted to look
up anything quickly,
we would have to create
ancillary tables that
would store indices to allow
us to do things very quickly.
And if we wanted to add a
totally new type of data,
we would have to
rethink our schema.
So what we typically do is we
create this exploded schema.
Because our triple stores
are very comfortable
dynamically storing very
large numbers of columns.
So we essentially typically take
the type and append the value.
So we create a series
of triples here,
usually with some
minimal information
for the actual stored
value, something
we would never want to look up.
Again, by itself this
doesn't give you much.
Because most of these triple
stores have an orientation,
typically row oriented.
So you can get any row quickly
with relatively little effort.
And so we also store
the transpose of that.
We now create a table pair,
such that we can look up
any row or column very quickly.
And so essentially, we've
indexed all the data.
And you can now do things
very, very quickly.
So that's a very powerful,
powerful concept.
And we exploit it all time.
And of course,
this whole concept
looks very much like
an associative array.
Mathematically, we can treat
it as an associative array.
All right.
So that's sort of the easy part.
I think we've
covered a lot of this
before in previous lectures.
Now, we're going
to get into some
of the more mathematical
elements, which
aren't necessarily hard.
They just impose notation
that we don't necessarily
use in our regular
day to day work lives.
So we're going to
talk about what
are the values associations,
keys, functions,
and getting into things
like matrix multiply.
So mathematically, we
treat an associative array
as sets of keys
and values that are
drawn from infinite strict
totally ordered set,
we'll call it S. You might
be like, what is that?
What is an infinite strict
totally ordered set?
It's just a set where
there's an ordering, where
basically any two
elements in the set,
there's a function
that will tell you
one is greater than the other.
And they also have an
equal operation, too.
So it will tell you that,
you know, to give it any two
values, I can ask the question
is one greater than the other
or are they equal?
So that's the strict part.
So that encompasses a lot.
Obviously, it encompasses the
usual things like real numbers,
and integers, and
things like that.
But it also encompasses
strings if we
impose an ordering on them.
And we will choose lexicographic
ordering almost always
to be our order.
In fact, in the implementation,
we sort of impose that.
We always use
lexicographic ordering.
We don't really have another
ordering that is readily
at our disposal.
So given those keys and
values, an associative array
is a partial function
from a d dimensional set
of keys to a value.
So if we have the vector of
key, so typically d will be 2.
And the first k1 will be the
row key, and then a column key.
And it will map out
its partial function
from the d keys to one value.
So it will look like
this, an associative array
with a vector of
keys, typically 2.
I will have a value vi and
that it is empty otherwise.
So this is its function,
because we only define it
where these keys exist.
So you can Imagine that
every singe associative
array is a function
over the entire space
of all possible keys.
But we're only giving you
the ones that are defined.
And everywhere else,
it's undefined.
OK.
This is actually a fairly large
break from linear algebra,
where we can have functions--
a matrix is really
a function of the indices, the
ij indices, which are integers.
Here, we allow them
to be anything.
And we formally
support the concept
of a completely
empty row or column.
So associative arrays
don't allow that.
They only store not
empty information.
And in our implementation, we
tend to store 0 as equivalent
to null in this space.
Because the underlying
sparse matrix implementation
does that.
0 is essentially treated
as the null character.
So that's a big difference.
Now, we can still use our
linear algebraic intuition,
but that's the fundamental
difference here.
So binary operations
on any two associative
arrays-- so I have
associative array
A1 and A1 with this
binary operation--
are defined essentially
by two functions.
The sort of upper
function here says how
we're going to treat the keys.
So if we have two
associate arrays,
their keys, some of
them can overlap.
Some of them cannot overlap.
And our function
will either choose
to look for the union or
the intersection of those.
So for instance,
if we do addition,
that's most associated with
unioning the underlying keys.
If we do other operations,
like and, that's
most consistent
with intersecting
the two sets of keys.
So obviously, if
it's union-like,
the result will
always be non-empty.
If the function is
intersection-like,
then there's a possibility
you can do a binary operation.
And the result will be an
empty associative array.
So we have that choice there.
And we choose union
and intersection,
because they're the
ones that are-- you
could do other functions.
But they're the ones that are
formally covered in set theory
and keep us from having
to relax this very
general condition here.
We can have equality.
So we can check
for intersection.
And so we're OK there.
So if we have an
associative array,
A1 with a set of keys
here, ki, and a value, v1,
and another associative
array with an intersecting
ki with v2, then A3 ki will
be given by this function.
It's either going to
be the keys overlap.
So if ki are the
same, they'll overlap.
And so there you go.
And likewise, with this.
You have this choice.
It could either be a
union or an intersection.
And then what we do
with the values-- like,
we now have the collision
is what we'll call these.
Two keys from two associative
arrays, the row keys
and the column
keys are the same.
Well, now, we want
to do something.
We apply this function f, which
we call the collision function.
And that will determine what
the actual result is, what
the new value of A3 will be.
If one of these was empty, then
obviously the union of this we
don't even have
to worry about it.
That's kind of the
way we approach this.
If there is no
collision, so that
means you're applying
your function with this,
then f is never called.
So we always just
do that or that.
So if it's a union
function, then you just
get v. If it's an
intersection function,
then you would just
get the empty set.
And the underlying
function never is called.
And you might be like, well,
why would I care about that?
Well, later on I'm going to get
to deal with things like, well,
what is the zero in this math?
Or what is one in this math?
And this will allow me to sort
of address some of those cases
by saying, look, if there's
no key intersection,
we can do that.
So the high level usage
of associative arrays
is essentially dictated
by this mathematics.
And again, part of the reason
we chose this very general
definition is that,
by definition,
numbers, reals, and integers
are all included here.
We have not thrown them out.
And we've also included strings.
I should say at any time we can
say, look, our values are just
real numbers.
And then we essentially get the
full power of linear algebra.
But that's true of
this sort of card
that we always
try and play last.
OK.
We try and keep our
mathematics as broad as we can.
And if then there's
particular instances like,
oh, well, I need the values
to be real numbers or complex
numbers here, or
integers, or whatever.
We can always say, all
right, the values are that.
And now, we get a whole bunch
of additional properties.
But we try and build
up the mathematics
in this general way first, and
then sort of play that later.
AUDIENCE: Question.
JEREMY KEPNER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the way you've--
the general definition of keys,
that's more general than
you would need to analyze
spreadsheets.
Wouldn't it be sufficient
for spreadsheets
to have your keys be
integers [INAUDIBLE]?
JEREMY KEPNER: So I believe
that actually spreadsheets
store things as R1, and R2, R3
internally and C1, that they
actually use a internal
triple representation,
and then project that
into this integer space.
So what the actual
spreadsheet does, I think,
kind of depends on the
specific spreadsheet.
So the question was-- they can't
really hear you on this mic.
Is this more than you
need to do a spreadsheet?
Could you get away with
just integer indexing?
And I would say perhaps.
I don't really know.
And as I said, I
think internally they
actually do something
that's more akin to this.
Certainly when you do
math in Microsoft Excel,
it has letters.
You give it A1, B1,
those types of things.
AUDIENCE: But that's just
because they're using letters
instead of a second integer.
JEREMY KEPNER: Yeah.
Yeah.
One could view it that way.
But people like it.
So we do what
people like, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But you don't need an additional
mathematical structure.
[INAUDIBLE]
You can just make it one to
one [INAUDIBLE] letters to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
like in Excel, you
have different worksheets,
too, and different columns.
So you have to
reference both of those.
AUDIENCE: You have to
reference row and column.
But you just need
a pair of integers.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
a row and column.
But then it's also the
worksheets that you're on.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So, three.
AUDIENCE: So there's three.
But they're not going to
sequentially number all those.
Because it's a sparse space that
you're using, right, probably?
So I'm sure they
do some caching.
I don't think they store
a number for every column
that you're not using.
AUDIENCE: Certainly,
you can try that out
by creating an
empty spreadsheet,
putting the number
in one corner,
putting a number in another
corner really far away
and see if it [INAUDIBLE]
two [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY KEPNER: It
doesn't do that.
Obviously, it does compress.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY KEPNER: Yeah.
So mathematically, it may be
more than what is minimally
required to do a spreadsheet.
We will discover,
though, it is very useful
and, in a certain sense,
allows you to do things
with spreadsheets
that are hard to do
in the existing technologies,
which is why I use it.
There's operations
that I can do with this
that are very natural.
And the spreadsheet
data is there.
And I would like to
be able to do it.
AUDIENCE: So Jeremy?
JEREMY KEPNER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The actual
binary operator
plus in associative array,
is it union or intersection?
JEREMY KEPNER: So
on the keys, it
will be union where the
value is an intersection
with an empty set.
We don't care what the
actual numerical thing is.
We'll just return
the other thing.
Where there is a collision, and
so now you have to resolve--
and that's kind of why we
get a lot of mileage here.
Because most of the time,
we are very few collisions.
And so it's not like we have
to worry about huge things.
So where there are collisions,
if the values are numbers,
then it'll just do
the normal addition.
If the values are strings,
then it's somewhat undefined
what we mean there.
And I forget if D4M throws
an error in that situation
if the values are strings.
It might default to
just doing something
like taking the max
or the min and saying,
you tried to add two things
for which the formal addition
collision function
doesn't really make sense.
And I'm just going to
put something in there.
We can test that out at
the end of the class.
AUDIENCE: So a
collision function
is a function of that
type of the value?
JEREMY KEPNER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JEREMY KEPNER: It
has to be a function
of the type of the value.
Because if I'm going to add
a real number with a string,
what do I do?
Because I can do that.
Yes, another question.
AUDIENCE: To follow up
on the previous point,
it seems like in the case
for addition, for example,
there might be cases where you'd
actually want union, then add,
or intersection, then add.
It kind of depends on what
the nulls in your array
actually represent.
JEREMY KEPNER: Oh, there
are so many functions
where you can think,
well, I'd kind of
like to have it mean
this in this context.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So the question
is can you pass in
as a parameter in D4M I want
you to union, then operate,
I want you to
intersect, then operate?
Or did they all just assume
the most logical and do it?
So bigger lever question
was sometimes you
maybe would like
plus to mean some
of the other conceptual
ways that we would mean it.
OK.
So in fact, we see that a lot.
There's a lot of things.
Now, in fact, we'll
get into that space.
And there's hundreds,
thousands, millions
of potential possible algebras
that you can possibly want.
So what we have done is we
think about the function.
And we think about in
this mathematical context.
And we see what its
mathematical implications
are in terms of is it consistent
with the overall group
theory of the
mathematics, in which case
we know that if someone uses it
that the intuition will carry
through?
Or is it kind of
forking them off
into it's something
you might want to do,
but really the result
is now taking you
into a sort of undefined space?
So that's kind of a thing
we use for doing that.
We don't have the formal support
in this of a multiply operation
that allows you to
pass in an arbitrary
function for doing that.
I should say there are
various tricks that
allow you to do that in
just a couple lines or two.
Basically, what
you can do is you
start with give me the
intersection of the unions
first.
Now, I know I have
only collisions.
Now, give me the values.
Apply whatever
operator you want.
Stuff the values back
in, and you're done.
And so you can kind of
work your way through that.
And by doing that, you're doing
it in a way such that you know,
yeah, you're outside
of an algebra here.
You're just kind of
doing what you're doing.
So encourage people to do that.
But I'm just
telling you in terms
of how we choose what functions
we pull and formally support.
And there's a few that
I've been wrestling
with for a long time,
for a very long time
and just haven't been
able to decide what to do.
Maybe I should just
make a decision.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like a
real simple example,
if I had an array, one,
two, three, and ray
b was null on all three, there
would only be one collision.
And if we were in add, it would
only add them at the last--
JEREMY KEPNER: No.
If it was an addition, it was--
AUDIENCE: So one, two, three.
And then the other one
was null, null, three.
JEREMY KEPNER: So but they have
the same column or something?
These are vectors?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JEREMY KEPNER: These
are row vectors?
Yes.
So basically we have a one
column vector with three,
another column with one.
And when we add them together,
you would get a three.
Because it would be union.
It would union the keys.
And then the only
addition operation
would be performed
on the collision.
We did one or and an and
operation, then the result
would just be one,
an associative array
with one element in it.
AUDIENCE: And we can do either
one depending on the context?
I kind of lost you there.
Because the question was is
it union or intersection.
JEREMY KEPNER: It
depends on the operation.
So plus formally is
closer to set addition,
and so therefore, is
a union operation.
And is formally closer
to set intersection,
and so it's an intersection
operation there.
Regardless, in both cases,
the collision function
is only applied where
there is a collision.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm getting a
little confused by [INAUDIBLE]
formally defined operations
on associative arrays
in terms of values.
You've used a quality
on keys at this point.
You haven't defined any other
operations such as [INAUDIBLE]
intersection [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY KEPNER: Well, so
the keys are part of a set.
And so they get the union
and intersection properties
of strict totally
ordered set, which
is the intuitive use of union.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But they belong to the
same set, [INAUDIBLE]
the same [INAUDIBLE] set.
Yet, you've only defined
binary operations
on associative arrays.
You haven't defined them
on the elements of the set.
JEREMY KEPNER: So we'll get
into that a little bit later.
AUDIENCE: That's what I thought.
JEREMY KEPNER: But
they essentially
have the binary operations of
a strict totally ordered set,
which is equality and less than.
AUDIENCE: It seems to me
the bulk of the questions
were about manipulations
on keys we haven't even
talked about yet.
JEREMY KEPNER: Yes.
Yes.
Well, there's another
40 some slides.
But actually, you've gotten a
lot of the good questions here.
So the thing though to
recognize is that there's
a lot of choices here.
And the algebra you are in
is determined by the function
that you choose.
And actually,
you'll find yourself
switching between different
algebras fairly frequently.
That's how we use spreadsheets.
Sometimes we do this operation,
and now we're in this algebra.
And we do this operation,
now we're in this algebra.
And so that's the big thing
to kind of get away there.
So let's get into this
a little bit more.
That's sort of the big overall.
So I think we've
talked about this.
Let S is an infinitely
strict totally ordered set.
Total order Is an
implementation, not
a theoretical requirement.
So the fact that we were
imposing this infinite strict--
that they're totally
ordered, that we don't just
allow equality, is more of
an implementation detail.
It is very useful for
me to internally store
things in order so I could
look things up quickly.
However, mathematically,
strictly, we just
had a test of equality, all
the math hangs together there.
All value's and keys
are drawn from the set.
And the allowable operations
on them, of two values or keys,
is less than, equal
to, or greater than.
So those are the three functions
that we essentially allow.
Strict totally
ordered set only is
two, which is less than,
less than or equal to.
But you get essentially
the third one for free.
In addition, we have the
concept of three special symbols
here, which we've
talked about, which
is the null, the empty set,
a least element in the set,
and a maximal
element to the set.
So v less than or equal to
plus infinity is always true.
And plus infinity
is, we're saying,
the maximal element
is a part of this set.
Greater than or equal
to negative infinity
is always true.
In all set theory, the empty set
is a formal member of all sets.
So now we'll talk about--
did that sort of get
to your question about
the operations that
are defined on the keys?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
You [INAUDIBLE]--
JEREMY KEPNER: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So then we talked about
the collision functions.
And there are two sort
of contextual functions
here, union and intersection.
Because there's the two
operations that makes sense.
And then three conditions,
less than, equal to,
or greater than.
That is in order to preserve
this strict totally ordered
set.
Once I go to values that
are reals or integers,
I have more operations.
But if I'm just limiting
myself to values
that are members of a
strict totally ordered set,
this is all I have.
So that means that you have
d plus 5 possible outcomes
to any collision function.
That is, you could have the
collision function actually
choose to put out the value
of its underlying key.
You could produce
v1 or v2 or empty
or minus infinity or
plus or sets of these.
So it's a fairly finite
choice of results.
If we're going to stay in
this sort of restricted thing,
we have a very limited
number of things
that can actually happen.
When you're actually
applying a collision function
on a particular where
there's an intersection,
you have a fairly
finite number of things.
However the total number of
combinations of these functions
gives a very large number.
And their function pairs
gives a very large number
of possible algebras.
I did a back
[INAUDIBLE] calculation
said it was 10 to the 30th.
It might be even more that.
And in fact, it
might be formally
infinite for all I know.
But that was an
easy calculation.
There's a lot of
possible algebras.
And this is a fairly
impressive level
of functionality given our
relatively small numbers
of assumptions
that we have here.
But we are going to focus here
on just the nice collection
functions, the ones that seem
to feel like they give us
intuitively useful things.
So we are not going to use
keys as outputs to our function
here.
OK.
We will in some contexts.
And we're going to say
the results are always
single valued.
We're not going to
deal with results,
expand our values to
be sets of values.
Although, in certain
contexts we will do that.
But mathematically, let's
restrict ourselves to that.
We're going to do no
tests on special symbols.
And we're just going to
basically say our collision
function can be
essentially-- if we
have v, less than
v2, the answers can
be one of these five.
If it's equal to these, it
can be one of these four.
If it's greater than these,
it can be one of these five.
So it gives a fairly limited
number of possible collision
functions.
And all these properties
are consistent with strict
totally ordered set.
And generally, when we
handle a value of this,
it's handled by the union and
intersection function first.
It never actually gets passed
through to this function.
All right.
So let's move on here.
And just as I said, well,
what about concatenation?
In fact, there
are contexts where
we will want to concatenate
a couple of strings together
or something like that.
And you know, that's
fairly supported.
I think the results can
be the sets themselves.
You would have a
new special symbol,
which is the set itself.
You have now different
collision functions.
So you have union.
And then I want a union
values as our intersect,
and then union values and
union and intersection.
So those are your
functions there.
And there's actually
a few instances.
I think we've already showed one
of them in one of the examples
where we actually do this.
So I'm just sort of
throwing that in there
that concatenation is a
concept that we do think about.
I don't think we've developed
the formalism as richly
in a situation where the values
are simply single values.
But we certainly
can and do do that.
AUDIENCE: Jeremy.
JEREMY KEPNER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Third example,
was that [INAUDIBLE]
for identity instead of union?
[INAUDIBLE]
JEREMY KEPNER: This one here?
AUDIENCE: No, go up.
Get a little bit to the left.
The symbol-- [INAUDIBLE]
was upside down.
AUDIENCE: I have a
similar question.
Is the one above it [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY KEPNER: Yeah.
I might have a typo here.
I should double check that.
Yeah.
So v union that.
All right, so that should
be an intersection.
And that should be union.
And that should be intersection.
So I just got them
to flop there.
So thank you.
Full marks to you.
We will make that change.
All right.
So that one is
intersection, correct?
And this
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JEREMY KEPNER: --three
should be intersection.
All right.
Very good.
We'll check in the SVN.
In the next down time, it will
be part of your [INAUDIBLE].
Moving on.
All right.
So one of the things
we're eventually
going to work towards is trying
to make matrix multiply work
in this context.
OK.
We've already talked
about the duality
between the fundamental
operation of grass,
which is breadth first search
and vector matrix multiply.
We continue to want to
be able to use that.
It's a very powerful feature.
And what we find is that in
graph algorithms, where we're
dealing with things on strings
or other types of operations,
that most graph algorithms
can be reduced to operations,
what are called on semi-rings.
So those are generalizations of
normal linear algebra, whereby
your two core operations here,
what is called the element
wise multiply and the
element addition operation,
are this has the property
of being associative
and distribute over
the plus operation.
And plus has the
property of being
associative and commutative.
And examples of this include
the traditional matrix multiply
plus and multiply,
min.+, or max.+.
In fact, there's
a whole sub branch
of algebra called max plus
algebras, which do this.
Another one is or.and and
other types of things.
So mathematically, semi-rings
are certainly well-studied more
in the context of specific
algebras, like min.+, min+,
or max+, or something like that.
Here, with the
associative arrays,
we're dealing with
you could be hopping
and popping back and forth
within the same expression.
You could be moving
back and forth
between these
different algebras.
So I think that's a
little bit different.
We're taking sort of a bigger
view, a more data-centric view.
Our data can be of different
kinds, and then impose upon it
different algebras
as we move forward.
And the real theory
questions that we're
trying to answer here
is we have this concept
of associative arrays,
which is kind of new.
We have the traditional
linear algebra.
And there's going to be
areas where they overlap.
Your ideas, your intuition
from linear algebra,
and your intuition
from associative arrays
will be very, very
well-connected.
OK.
And there's going to places
where associative arrays
give you new properties that you
didn't have in linear algebra.
And those will allow
you to do new things.
And there's going to be cases
where your linear algebra
intuition is wrong.
That is, taking your
linear algebra intuition
and applying it to
associative arrays
will lead you into things
that won't make sense.
And so this is
kind of what we're
trying to give people a sense
here, of where they overlap,
where you should watch out, and
where there's new properties
that you didn't know about that
you should maybe take advantage
of.
The biggest one being
the universal conformance
of addition and multiplication
of all associative arrays.
So any two associative arrays,
regardless of their size,
can be multiplied and added to
each other unlike traditional
linear algebra, where you
have very strict constraints
about the dimensions of matrices
in order for them to be added.
And we do use this all the time.
We use this all the time,
essentially almost exactly
in the example that
we talked about.
It was a question that
was brought up earlier.
We can add a vector
of three elements
and a vector of five
elements and have
something that makes sense.
OK.
Likewise, we can multiply
a 10 by 12 with a 6 by 14
and have something that
actually makes sense.
So that's a very
powerful concept.
And I'd say it's one of the
most commonly used features.
All right.
So we've done the
basic definition.
Now, we're going
to kind of probably
move a little bit quicker
here into the group theory.
So the group theory is when
you pick various functions.
What kind of algebra's
a result of that?
So we're going to talk
about binary operators,
and then get into commutative
monoids, semi-rings, and then
something we call the feld.
So our joke there
is that so a field
is when you do the traditional
mathematics of linear algebra.
You're doing them over the
real field or the complex field
of numbers.
It's a set of numbers with
certain defined properties.
OK.
When we impose this
condition that we
are doing with strict
totally ordered sets,
we don't have an
additive inverse.
There's no way to
formally subtract
two words from each other.
We can't have a string
and a negative string.
So we don't get,
like, a and minus a,
which is part of a field.
So we have is feld, which is
a field without an inverse.
So mathematicians
are very funny.
And when they do
this, they often
will drop the i or something
like that to make that concept.
So we will be
doing math over a--
we can have much of the
properties of linear algebra.
We just have to recognize that
we don't have additive inverse.
So it's sort of like
vector spaces over felds.
Or sometimes they're
called semi-vectors spaces.
You can put semi in
front of anything.
And it's like it's a little bit
of this, but minus something.
So this is kind of
our operator roadmap.
So you see here, we began
with three definitions.
We will have narrowed it down
to 200 operators of interest
of those nice collision
functions and union functions.
There's about 200
combinations that work well.
We will find that 18 of those
operators are associative.
So not associative in
terms of associative array,
but associative in terms of
the formal mathematical concept
of associativity.
And so those form what
are called semigroups.
14 of them are
commutative, which means
they are Abelian semigroups.
Commutativity, that
just means that you can
switch the order of operations.
a plus b is the
same as b plus a.
Not something that is
a strict requirement.
But gosh, it's sure
nice to have to not
have to be like oh, no,
I switched the order.
And now the answer is different.
So traditional matrix
multiply is like that, right?
a times b is not the
same thing as b times a.
And we will have that as well.
But commutativity
is really nice.
We then take these 14
operations and explore
all their possible pairs.
There's 196 of them.
We look at which one
of them distribute.
There's 74 that distribute,
so they form semirings.
We then look to see if we have
an identity and an annihilator.
Some of our special
symbols, can they
perform that role in which
case they can form a feld?
And then we can
create, essentially,
vector semi-spaces or vector
spaces over these felds.
And we'll have about 18 of
them when we're all done.
And the good thing
is when you get
all done with this, all
the ones that you like
are still in the game.
And a few of the ones you might
like, some of my favorites,
they don't get as far down
this path as you want.
But then you have
these properties.
And you're like, OK, I have
vector space properties
and other types of things.
And I'm sure some of you
will find issues or comments
or criticisms that we haven't
written this up formally
in journals.
I've been desperately trying
to hire abstract algebraists
as summer students and have
not been successful so far.
So if you know any
abstract algebraists that
would like to work
on this, we would
be happy to pay them to
help us work on this.
If we extend our
definition of values
to include sets, ie, to
include concatenation,
this is essentially
what it does.
It adds four functions here.
They actually make it through
all these operations here.
And they basically
keep on going.
But then they fall away
here when we try and get
to this final feld step.
But you know, this is still
a very useful space to be in.
All right.
So let me explain
a little bit of how
we sort of navigate this space.
So if we can limit ourselves to
special function combinations
that are associative and
commutative-- so just remember,
associative just means you can
group your parentheses however
you want.
I always have to look it up.
Never once been
like associative--
I mean, I don't know.
It's never been intuitive to me.
But that's the grouping
of parentheses.
Commutativity just
means that you can flip.
So these are our functions.
So these are all the 18 here.
And then the grade-- one's
grade out of the ones you lose,
because of the commutativity.
So basically this
function, which
is just left, which just
says return the left value
in all circumstances,
well, obviously, that's
not commutative.
And quite frankly,
left and right are
sort of silly functions.
You Sometimes it almost
is essentially a no op.
If you knew you
want the left value,
you just take the left
value and move on.
So that doesn't
really-- so then we're
left with a lot of ones we
like, essentially union max.
So basically, take the
max value, union min.
I call this the intersection
delta function just return.
It only gives you an answer
if the values are the same.
This is essentially the union.
It's sort of like
the x or function.
If there's a collision,
blow it away.
And then there are
very sort of other kind
of more unusual
combinations here dealing
with the special functions.
We tend to kind of
really live mostly here.
These tend to be
the ones that really
are the ones you use a lot.
I haven't really
used these too much.
All right.
And so we're left with
these, what are called,
Abelian semigroups are these
14 highlighted ones here.
AUDIENCE: So Jeremy, I feel
I'm going to get lost here.
What does Abelian mean?
JEREMY KEPNER: So Abelian is a
semigroup that is commutative.
That's all it means.
So basically, it means
you have associativity.
And then it's Abelian if
you add commutativity to it.
So any sets of numbers that
obey grouping operations
and are commutative is Abelian.
I mean, I think
Abel did a lot more
that he didn't need to get
his name associated with that.
It could have just been called
comm-- it's sometimes just
called a commutative semigroup.
So you know, it's
lucky when you get
your name added to some
really trivial operation.
I mean, he did a lot of things.
But they threw him on here.
And in fact, in group theory,
they complain about this.
And there are numerous
rants about how they've
named all their
groups after people,
and they don't
tell you anything.
As opposed to other branches of
mathematics, who would simply
just call this a commutative
semigroup or just a commutative
associative group.
That might be even more-- and
of all the different properties,
most of them you can combine
in whatever you want.
There's almost an
infinite number of groups.
So there's certain ones
that are most useful.
Let's see here.
So now, we start--
AUDIENCE: Along those
lines, what's the--
and I'm sorry if
you already said
this-- distinction between
a semigroup and a group?
JEREMY KEPNER: A
group and a semigroup.
I want to say-- oh, it's an
Abelian group without inverses.
So a semigroup there.
So these are all Abelian
semigroup or Abelian groups
without inverses or
commutative associative groups
without inverses.
So you see the problem.
And so I guess, he
studied them a lot.
So he got his name
associated with them
and proved their
properties and stuff.
So we have 14 of those
that form 196 pairs.
So these will begin
to-- so we want
to look at the ones
that are distributive.
So that basically means we
assign one of those operators
to be the addition
operation, the other to be
the multiplication operation.
And we need to show
that it is distributive.
And of those 196, 74 operator
pairs are distributive.
These are called semirings.
Or they could be called rings.
So a semiring is a ring
without an inverse, so rings
without inverses and
without identity elements.
And if you look at the
various definitions,
I mean, there's the
Wikipedia definition,
which mathematicians will
say is that's not really
a true definition.
There's a Wolfram
math rule definition,
which is more rigorous.
And they often
disagree on this stuff.
I tend to be like if
Wikipedia says is true,
then most people
on the planet Earth
believe that that
is what is true.
And so therefore, you should
be aware that is the truth
that most people will believe.
So I don't know which one
we've chosen here, whether it's
the Wikipedia or the Wolfram.
There's also various
encyclopedias
that define this stuff, too.
AUDIENCE: Jeremy?
JEREMY KEPNER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you define ring?
JEREMY KEPNER: Define what?
AUDIENCE: Ring.
JEREMY KEPNER: Ring?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JEREMY KEPNER: Oh, uh,
well, a ring would be this.
And it would have inverses
and identity elements.
So it's basically
something that satisfies
that's distributive and has
inverses and identity elements.
But if you type ring in the
Wiki-- and I should say,
the great thing about Wikipedia
is like all the definitions
are linked.
So after seven or eight clicks,
it kind of all holds together.
So it's pretty nice.
And Wolfram is the same
way, just enough knowledge
to be dangerous.
The internet's
your friend, right?
So moving on here.
And this is something that's
less important, but kind
of for completeness if we're
going to head towards vector
space, we need to address,
which is the concept of identity
elements.
So zero is the
additive identity.
When you think of normal math,
you add zero to something,
it doesn't change it.
And the choices for
additive identity elements,
we have three special symbols,
and we could pick them.
We have the multiplicative
identity, which is 1,
and the multiplicative
annihilator.
So of the choices here,
we have 12 semirings
with the appropriate
zeros and ones.
We have four that actually
have two combinations.
And we have 16 total
operations-- of the 16,
there are 6 operators.
These are different operators.
And again, we call these
felds without inverses.
I'll get into it
a little bit more.
So for instance-- and we
can skip that for now.
So just a better way to
look at that is these
are our operator pairs.
OK.
And we wanted to see
which one of the them
sort of form these felds.
So the ones that distribute
are marked with a D here.
The ones that
distribute and have
a 0, 1 operator pair that works,
are shown in the square here.
And some of them have two.
So if I pair [INAUDIBLE]
plus union min
and multiply a intersection
min, and I define 0
to be the empty value,
and 1 to be plus infinity,
then I can create a feld,
essentially, out of that.
I had a lot of debate with
someone about this one,
whether I can have plus
infinity be the 0 element
and have it be less
than the 1 element.
Was there a requirement that
0 actually be less than 1
in this definition?
When I talked to
mathematicians, they're like,
eh, it's kind of what you
want, then you make it that.
So this just shows
the full space
of things that are possible.
If we go back to our
concatenation operators here,
so these were our four
concatenation operators
and our collision functions.
And this shows you what
that set looks like.
So these are the four
by four pairs here.
All operators, they
all distribute.
And 16 of these form semirings.
Because you're able to
construct these various zeroes.
And this isn't, like, rigorous.
I mean, I might have messed one
up or a few up here or there
or something like that.
But this just kind
of gives you a sense
of the space that
we're working on.
AUDIENCE: You made some typos on
that table [? you ?] fix later.
JEREMY KEPNER: Probably.
Probably.
Now, I'm going to kind of
really move it forward here.
So we get into vector spaces.
So we can have associative
array vector addition.
Again, all associative
arrays are conformant.
We have the concept of
scalar multiplication,
which is essentially
applied to all values.
So one of the things
I really struggle
with-- so scalar multiplication
kind of makes sense, right?
If I have an associative array
and I multiply it by a scalar,
I can imagine just applying
that in an intersection
sense only to the keys
are defined by one.
Scalar addition, though,
is very difficult.
If I have a scalar plus
an associative array,
does it only apply to the keys?
Or is a scalar really
the associative
array that's defined
everywhere over all things?
So it's infinite.
So that's something
I struggle with.
So when you ask why is scalar
addition not supported in D4M,
it's because I don't know
what it's supposed to mean.
And you can easily just
pop out the values,
add whatever you want,
stuff them back in,
and can be on your way.
And then your safe.
So in the vector
space that we form,
it meets the plus requirements.
It commutes.
It's associative.
We have an identity.
But we have no inverse.
So we have to be careful.
That's why we don't have add.
And a vector space, it meets
the scalar requirements.
So all associative
array operator
pairs that yield felds,
also result in vector spaces
without inverse spaces.
Maybe we call these vectors
semispaces, I don't know,
or vector spaces over a
feld or something like that.
What kind of properties here?
Well, we have scale identities.
That's great.
You could create subspaces.
That makes sense, too.
The concept of a span,
yes, you can definitely
do concepts of spans.
Does span equal a subspace?
So this is a big
question in vector space
theory, spans on subspaces.
Not sure.
Linear dependence.
Is there a nontrivial
linear combination
of vectors equal to
the plus identity?
You really can't do this
without an additive inverse.
And so that becomes
a little bit--
so we really kind of need to
redefine linear independence,
which we can do.
But there's a lot of the
proofs of linear independence
and dependence that rely on
the existence of inverses.
And you probably could
circle your way around that.
AUDIENCE: Question.
Are you just missing
the additive inverse
or both the additive
and the [INAUDIBLE]?
JEREMY KEPNER: Both.
Both, yeah.
Yeah.
So one of the things
is considering
a linear combination of two
associative array vectors.
Under what conditions do
they create a unique result?
So this really depends
on what you choose.
So for instance, if we
have a vector A1 and A2,
when we multiply it by
coefficients A1 and A2,
and we use these as our
plus and our multiply,
and this is our 0 and 1, where
are A1 uniquely determined?
And so for instance, if
I pick, in this case,
our canonical identity
vectors, which is A1
is equal to infinity
and minus infinity here,
then we find that we can
cover the space very nicely.
If we do it the other, we can't.
A better way to view that
is in the drawing here.
So here's my whole space
of coefficients A1 and A2.
And we see that A1 and A2
uniquely define a result
with these basis vectors.
And A1 and A2 are completely
degenerate with these basis
vectors.
So depending on the kinds
of basis vectors you have,
you can create unique
stuff or not unique stuff.
You can give yourselves
actual values here.
Basically, if A1 is
just equal to this value
and A2 is equal to
this value, this
shows you what that looks like.
There's places
where it's unique.
There's places where
they're the same.
And there's places
where one is unique,
but the other is not unique.
So again, you can construct
using associative arrays
as basis vectors, a
very rich set of things.
And the same thing goes
with multivalued vectors.
Again, different
types of spaces here.
We really need to
kind of work this out.
If anybody's
interested, we're very
interested in having people
help us work this stuff out.
Which of these
operations make sense?
Transpose makes total sense.
Transposing of associative
arrays makes total sense.
And it's a very efficient
operation, by the way, in D4M.
You can do transposes
very efficiently.
It works out very nicely.
Special matrices, submatrices,
zero matrices, square matrices,
diagonal matrices, yes.
Although, diagonal matrices
are a little bit tricky.
Upper and lower triangular,
yes, you can kind of do this.
Skew symmetric, no.
Hermitian, not really.
Elementary and row
column, sort of.
Row column equivalence, sort
of, under certain conditions.
These are all things you
can do in linear algebra.
And sometimes you can do
them with associative arrays
and sometimes you can't.
You have to think about them.
Matrix multiply is sort
of our crown jewel.
Always conformant-- can multiply
any sizes whenever you want.
There's two ways to
think about this.
You can make your head hurt
a little bit when you start
dealing with the no elements.
When does the union
operator get applied?
And when the-- so when
you do computation,
there's two ways to
formulate a matrix multiply.
There's the inner
product formulation,
which is typically what
people use when they actually
program it up.
Because it tends to
be more efficient.
That's basically you take
each row and each column,
you do an inner product,
and then do the result. OK.
Mathematically, from
a theory perspective,
you get yourself in
less trouble if you
think in terms of the outer
product formulation, which
is basically you take
each row and vector,
you do the outer product
to form a matrix,
and then you take all of
these, and then combine them
all together with the operation.
And that, theoretically,
actually keeps you sane here.
And that's the way to think
about it mathematically.
Variety of matrix
multiplies examples,
I won't go into them here.
Obviously, they depend
heavily on what our collision
function, g, is here.
It gives you different values
and different behaviors.
The identity element, maybe a
left identity, right identity.
In some instances,
it seems to be OK.
But the identity [INAUDIBLE]
is a little bit tricky.
Inverses, boy, is it hard to
construct inverses when you
don't have underlying inverses.
I It's just really tricky.
And so, probably are not
going to get anything
that looks like an inverse.
You can do Eigenvectors in
certain restrictive cases
sort of.
And there are interesting
papers written about this.
But it's only on very--
the row and column keys
need to be the same and
stuff and so, you know.
One thing I really would like
to explore is the pseudoinverse.
So pseudoinverse A plus
satisfies these properties.
And I actually think
that will are probably
be in pretty good shape
for pseudoinverse.
And the pseudoinverse
is what you
need to solve the
least-squares problem.
And I think solving the
least-squares problem is
actually something we might
really be interested in doing
in some of our problems.
So I do need to work
this out if people would
like to explore this with me.
We have a whole set of theorems
that we'd like to prove.
Spanning theorems, linear
dependence, identities,
inverses, determinants,
pseudoinverses, Eigenvectors,
convolutions, for which
of these do these apply?
A lot of good math that
could be done here.
Call to arms for those people
who are interested in this type
thing.
So just to summarize,
you know, the algebra
of associative
arrays provides us
this mathematical foundation.
I think I've have tried to
show you the core parts that
are really well solid and
expand that to the points here.
You can see where it is,
while we don't really
know exactly what should
be happening here,
and give you a little bit a
logic behind how we do this.
A small number of
assumption really
yields a rich
mathematical environment.
And so I have a
short code example.
It's not really teaching
you anything new.
It's just to show you that I
tested all these properties
using D4M, which was nice
and really in a very kind
of spreadsheet kind of style.
And so I'm just going
to show you that.
There's really just one example.
It takes a few seconds to run.
And then the
assignments-- so these
are in this part
in the directory--
And then the assignment,
should you so do it--
if you didn't do the
last assignment, well,
you're going to need to do
that to now do this assignment.
So basically, for those of you
who did the last assignment--
array of a drawing and
looking at the edges
and stuff like that.
Now, I want you think about
that associative array.
And think about which
kind of these operations
would make sense if you were
to try and add them or multiply
them or whatever.
Just explore that a little bit.
And just write up, OK, I
think these kind of operations
would make sense here.
You know, addition would
make sense if it's union
and the collision function is
this or something like that.
You'll have to think about
what your values are.
It could just be your values
are just 1, something like that.
You might be like, oh, my values
are 0,1 and I want 1 plus 1
to equal 0.
So you might have an "or" or
"x or" operation or something
like that.
So just sort of think about
what your example was.
And think about these
ideas a little bit.
And just write a few sentences
on kind of what that means.
The last slide here is-- we
don't really get this question.
But if you want to compare
what the difference
between associative rays
are and the algebra defined
by Codd that sort of
is the basis of SQL,
there's this little
table that describes
some of the differences there.